bien la musique je vous le disais de
france roche est actuellement au palais
des congrès je la vois on va donc
retrouver starmania france roche
oui et starmania c'est l'opéra des
mythes là il y à la star de cinéma il ya
la star de la politique il ya la star
métaphysique qui s'appelle le grand
gourou il ya les stars de la révolte qui
sont les étoiles rouges on pourrait
aussi bien les appeler les blousons
noirs
il y a aussi la salle d'entraînement et
diyala ça rentre tout qu'est la
télévision alors michel berger pourquoi
depuis trois ans travaillez-vous à
starmania et qu'est ce qui vous a donné
cette idée
écoutez vous savez un compositeur a
toujours envie de faire un spectacle
musical alors je crois que c'est c'est
dans le fond l'idée tous les gens qui
font la musique mais moi j'ai toujours
pensé qu'on pouvait faire des spectacles
musicaux francophone disons plutôt que
français parce que là c'est une
collaboration avec un certain nombre de
gens qui viennent du québec
je crois qu'en français on peut faire un
grand spectacle musical pas l'image des
spectacles américain différent mais
qu'ils soient du même format 10 leçons
c'est à dire un spectacle très visuel
pour une grande salle
mais quelle idée avez vous voulu
exprimer parce que vos stars ce sont des
stars plus négative que positive à moi
je suis pas d'accord il vous fait elles
ont envie de l ont envie de
de faire briller leur étoile et je
trouve ça très au contraire très positif
mais les idées vous savez c'est pas
certainement pas spectacle à idées parce
que on a voulu surtout faire un
spectacle où les gens voient les choses
pour l'un d'eux
il s'amuse bien mais je crois que ce
qu'on a voulu un petit peu exprimé c'est
l'époque dans laquelle on vit dans
laquelle on va vivre et c'est un sujet
fantastique pour un peu un opéra rock
c'est idéal
c'est un peu de la science fiction oui
c'est un petit peu c'est la science
fiction d'aujourd'hui disons parce que
c'est pas dans l'em2 1500 c'est plutôt
en 2000 c'est à dire dans votre temps là
et pourquoi vous êtes vous associer à
québécois pour cette entreprise
écoutez d'abord moi j'ai voulu
travailler avec un acteur qui puisse
être un auteur vraiment pas seulement un
auteur de chansons mais un auteur
capable d'écrire vraiment un spectacle
et je pensais que plamondon était
vraiment un auteur comme ça et c'est pas
vraiment parce qu'ils étaient québécois
que j'ai choisi travailler avec lui ceci
dit le fait qu'ils soient dans le
continent américain et qui soit en même
temps très imprégné de la culture
européenne
je crois que ça a été un atout très
intéressant dans l'élaboration du
spectacle et vous en réclamant dont vous
êtes le parolier de diane dufresne
particulièrement et de beaucoup de
chanteuses québécoises
vous avez écrit vos chansons québécois
ou en français les deux 2 2 mais pas
pour starmania westermann c'était un
défi que j'avais à relever c'est à
décrire un spectacle complet qu'il soit
compris pas toute la francophonie
si vous voulez mais y'a pas il n'y a pas
d' expression québécoise de dampniat pas
dargaud français non plus il n'ya ni
viens dans mon char où c'est le pied non
et il ya eu parfois des moments très
drôles ou par exemple moment donné
j'avais mille m'ont parfois et michel
mézy montponnais le nom parfois en
français c'est pas de langage courant
jusqu'à mon compte tous les jours au
québec il ya en france ces deux langages
de comtesse alors j'ai demain on va dire
des fois déjà le nom des fois ça c'est
vraiment un gars je trouve vulgaire
alors finalement et c'est ce qu'est ce
que tu dirais je dirais quelquefois
j'aide à moi quelquefois je dirais pas
ça alors finalement l'ami de temps en
temps et vos personnages vous voulez
trouver tous positifs parce que vous
faites une charge à fond contre les
hommes politiques contre les gourous
contre dire que moi non moi l'expression
charge contre je ne sais pas l'esprit du
tout du spectacle c'est c'est plutôt
enfin je veux dire si on est contre on
est contre tellement tout le monde que
je deviens que ça devient autre chose
il vous est pourquoi alors tu vois je
suis ni pour ni contre moi je dépeint un
monde un monde dans lequel je vis je ne
porte pas de jugement enfin je dépeins
un peu la décadence de l'occident la
décadence xxème siècle aussi on est à la
fin d'un siècle on est à la fin d'un
moyen âge probablement à 20 la nouvelle
ère technologique on patauge entre 2
millénaire qui est sont des gens qui
essaient de survivre un peu ciblé sur
sur le passé parce que bon ce nouveau
monde qui nous arrive où tout va être
uniformisé ou qui va être complètement
dominé par la télévision
est-ce qu'il va rester de la place pour
l'individu est ce qu'il va rester la
place pour pour que chacun puisse faire
briller sa petite étoile à lui et on
filme quand même sur un chant d'espoir à
l'univers sera un appel on demande si
elle répond c'est que par franz och oui
voilà je crois que nous retrouverons
tout à l'heure tout d'abord à 12h45 pour
le début de notre journal est ensuite
plus longuement à partir de 13h10 13h
douce pour starmania donc au palais des
congrès début demain